It's time to play impromptu roulette. I
have built a free public speaking tool
that you can utilize and it's called
impromptu roulette. And the idea is that
there are 99 random questions. You spin
the wheel, you get a question, there's a
5 second countdown, and then you have to
answer it to the best of your ability.
And the questions are about
professional, personal, hypothetical,
fun, wisdom. Those are the categories.
So, let's give it a go. I'll spin the
wheel right now and I'll do my best to
answer one of these questions in real
time. What's the most underrated
communication skill
in the workplace?
The most underrated communication skill
in the workplace is the ability to
understand different people's
communication styles.
So, depending on personality profiles
and whichever system you're used to. So,
there's DISC, there's Myers-Briggs,
there's all these various personality
profile styles. And what we learn
through them is that
different people have different ways
they prefer to be communicated to. So,
somebody who is direct, they probably
want information that's straight to the
point. They are somebody who's probably
going to talk a lot and a lot versus
somebody who is more likely to be a
analytical person, analytical brained.
They want just pure data. Like give them
the numbers. And then there's the more
sociable people who want a conversation.
Come into my office, have a cup of
coffee. And then there's others who are
really shy to speak up in meetings and
they're very good listeners, but if
they're cut off constantly, that's
something that bothers them.
The underrated communication workplace
skill is really understanding your
colleagues and how they prefer to be
communicated to. So, if I'm speaking
with somebody who likes that analytical
information, I don't stroll in and start
talking about the weather and what I'm
doing on the weekend. No, I come in
prepared with the data that that person
wants to see.
versus somebody who's more on the
sociable side,
maybe I bring them a coffee and I plan
to block an hour in my calendar cuz
that's their communication preference.
This is a skill that if everyone
mastered, they would be much better off.
All right, I did it. The time is up.
This is how the tool works. So, I'd love
to see you go and experiment with it.
Within the video description, I'll have
a direct link to where you can try out
this tool for yourself. And as I
mentioned, it's absolutely free. It's
part of my speaker.com
website. But, for fun, let's give
another one a go. So, I've asked one
question and you can either hit the
wheel or you can just choose spin again.
So, I'll hit spin again.
It's going to spin here and let's see
what we land on.
What's one piece of career advice you
wish someone had given you earlier?
What wasn't explained to me when I
started my current full-time job
is how much of a role public speaking
would have
in that role. I took on the job title of
social media and communications
coordinator and I assumed that I would
be helping on the back-end, helping real
estate agents with their social media,
working on press releases,
working on real estate reports. This was
all what I expected to be taking on.
Quickly I learned that a big part of my
role was speaking to large rooms of
agents, real estate agents,
inspiring them to utilize social media.
That idea of public speaking being an an
important skill
is something that was still pretty early
in my career, but I wish I had grasped
it even earlier.
Because I think this is such a powerful
thing for any leader or anybody who
wants to level up in their career, the
ability to communicate effectively in
front of a room of people in real life,
on camera, that ability to make eye
contact, to speak confidently, to be
able to take a question that is asked
randomly and come up with a 2-minute
answer.
This is a skill that is so incredibly
beneficial in life. And while I'm
relatively young, just under 40,
I feel fortunate that I have developed
the skill at the point that I have, but
I wish
I could have gone back even earlier and
leveled up even quicker with regard to
that. I've also found a passion for
helping other people with their public
speaking skills.
2 seconds left on the timer as I finish
that up. The time is up. This is a lot
of fun, and my goal in building this
tool for you, this free tool,
is that you will have something that you
can practice. Maybe you build a routine
on a semi-regular basis. You're able to
give this a go as well. So, I really
hope this is beneficial. And just for
fun,
let's do one more. Spin the wheel, see
what we get. And I'm going to I'm going
to do a fun category question. So, I
just switched the category to fun. And
once again, I'll hit the wheel. It will
spin. Here's my fun question that's
coming up.
What's a TV show, film, or book you're
slightly embarrassed to admit you love?
Oh,
I love that I was asked this question.
My first year of college,
I was living in a basement suite.
And I'd fallen asleep the night before,
and then
I heard my roommate come into the room,
and he said, "Wait, are you up?"
And I woke up, and I said, "What?" And
he said, "Did you phone the police?"
I said, "What? Did I phone the police?
No."
And he said, "Okay, go back to sleep."
And he closed the door.
I thought this was a dream. And then
about 5 minutes later, there was a
louder knock
on my door, and a police officer walked
into my room. And he said, "Hey." He had
a flashlight, and he was shining it in
my eyes.
He said,
"Did you call the police?"
And I said, "What? No, I don't think
so." I pulled my cell phone from beside
my bed, and I looked. I said, "No, I
didn't call." And he said, "No, the call
came from the landline."
I said, "No, it wasn't me."
And then he said, "Is anyone else in
here with you?"
And I said, "No, it's just me in the
room."
And he said, "And this is your room?"
And he's shining the flashlight around.
I said, "Yes, yes, it's my room."
And then he shined the flashlight on a
Dawson's Creek poster
that I had, because I'm slightly
embarrassed to admit I love the show
Dawson's Creek.
And then he shined the flashlight back
in my eyes, and then back on the poster,
and then back in my eyes. And he said,
"I thought you said this was your room."
I said, "It is. It is."
And he said,
"Why is there a Dawson Creek poster?"
And so, I had to explain to the police
officer that I loved this show. So, that
was my slightly embarrassing show that
little afraid to admit, but it's a great
Joey, Pacey, Dawson,
the whole gang was amazing and I'll have
to tell a longer version of the story of
why there is a police officer cuz there
was actually a backstory there and that
is my time. As you can see, this is an
incredibly fun tool to use. It
tests your ability to integrate stories
and to think quickly because it's my
belief the hardest part of public
speaking is the part that we can't
prepare for. Long-form speeches become
actually sort of easy
when we know how to practice properly
and build that skill. But the idea of
getting asked a question after our
presentation from an audience member,
that can be really challenging. And so,
my goal with this tool is to help you
with that. Again, link is in the video
description. Go try it out. Test it out.
Let me know what you think. What
question did you get? How was it? Was
this tool helpful? I hope it was. Thank
you so much for watching this video and
check out the video YouTube's
recommending because this is where I
dive into table topics within
Toastmasters, which is a similar
concept. Thanks so much for watching
this one. I'll catch you on the next
video.